but for me it was like
it just didn't make sense first of all
like i'll make something and then want
to drop it right away right like i i am
very much work off the momentum of what
i'm doing and then i had a lot of major
label things happen to me and i worked
with a lot of major label people and
none of them had none of them were happy
like true i talked with nf about his
deal um i talked with all these
different artists about their deals and
and they all hated it and then at the
same time like hey kyle's back to being
indy kyle's back to be in india a lot of
people are going that route and so what
happened was i dropped the greatest blew
up i dropped the rise that went crazy
like i made a hundred forty four
thousand dollars first week when my [ __ ]
dropped so first of all you couldn't
tell me nothing how many sales off the
itunes yeah when people still copy [ __ ]
on itunes so i'm like oh we're going
crazy so after that i started comparing
my numbers because i'm seeing myself on
the charts next to these people and
i believe that race rimmer had sold 14
000 copies and i sold 12 000
and i'm just like looking at their album
and i'm like how much did they pay for
all these beats how much how much were
they paying all these articles how much
is their percentage that they get to and
how much did they walk away with and i'm
just like yo
if they got all this promotion i see
them everywhere and they only sold 2000
more copies of me that's crazy and then
i did you know tours and and did jimmy
fallon good morning america and saw the
way that labels were kind of run in that
situation a lot of money was wasted on
that whole thing and i'm just like
i'd be sick like i'd be when you get the
bill yeah there's no way you don't even
have control of how you spend that money
like it just gets spent just getting you
get the bill and then you've got to
recoup it yeah no thank you
i'd be pissed the closest thing what you
had like a little short time with red
bull music right or was that like a
thing no that never actually happened i
never signed with them i was meeting
with everybody like i met with atlantic
i i was talking with them really liked
them um
i liked uh dang what's the dude's name
he was eminem's guy
rosenberg no the other dude
i can't remember but there was one dude
that i really rocked with who i felt
like really saw my vision then i rocked
with tick over it at red bull and then
um with wendy at universal republic now
i was really close to signing with
universal republic but
that was in between doing my album i
already had the idea for asking on the
internet which they didn't understand
which i don't know why and then i was
doing jimmy fallon and all that and
seeing how that was playing out then
they flew me to new york multiple times
and the main cat at republic blew me off
and i'm like
y'all flew me here it was either two or
three times they flew me to new york to
specifically meet with him and he never
showed and i'm like if you're blowing me
off now
what you gonna do when you got me under
contract you're definitely not coming in
you're trying you're supposed to be
courting me right now did uh strange
ever try to sign you
weirdly strange and funk volume have
never tried to sign me
funk everybody thought that like oh he
turned down funk volume he turned down
strange neither one of them ever offered
me to do that's interesting which dame
told me he's like you're too similar so
why would i
why would i sign you you're pretty much
already ingrained in our you know fan
base fan base so what what more would it
add or add to you and add to us and then
with strange it was like
yeah they never offered me anything
either